thank you
[Music]
one of tick tocks most followed cosmetic
surgeons has reportedly been banned by
Australia's national health regulator
from performing any cosmetic surgery and
has been instructed to remove any
related posts from his social media wow
they [ __ ] up or what
Dr Daniel arnov amassed over 13 million
followers on Tick Tock where he
regularly posted viral videos of graphic
surgery scenes health information facts
and humorous videos on cosmetic surgery
featuring popular Trends in some video
Shadows profile he's also warned against
the dangers of surgeries including the
popular Brazilian butt lift which we've
extensively covered here on this show
because we're not enough we're
scientists is he is he because he's
violating patients rights is that what
why well if you want to get down to the
nitty-gritty there are literally times
where he'll be mid-surgery and then
he'll pull out his phone to shoot a tick
tock of this surgery
right so if he's like injecting
anesthetics or like living incident [ __ ]
cosmetic like lipo and stuff
oh yeah
I'm going to tonight
but like yeah he just here's one here's
one quote from one of the people who was
complaining about him he's in the middle
of surgery and he is stopping checking
the video then saying no I don't want
that cut that out do it again
uh so he's wasting that [ __ ] time
dude he doesn't have somebody else like
they're just filming for him they all
work for him too right he can't hire one
more person that's true I mean if it's
part of the contract when they go in
there right do they know in advance
you're gonna be a tick tock star does he
not tag them yeah
that's my gallbladder [ __ ] up part
it's like it's cool but if you don't tag
him dude it's like that's rude I did
this [ __ ] collab and I didn't even
get it created for you you [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ]
I mean people literally are uh also
because of like the improper surgical
procedures are like becoming
hospitalized some people after like
different surgery procedures are having
to see other doctors in order to fix
different things or like running into
pain when they go home like post
procedure and stuff yeah dude that's
nuts
[ __ ] up my surgery to make a viral
video pop socket in your [ __ ] lung
what the [ __ ] is this you could lean on
it and [ __ ] like oh it stays upright
that's crazy now but if you're a [ __ ]
surgeon be good at being a surgeon 100
of the time like you can't be [ __ ]
around with that's really good advice
yeah take care of your [ __ ] patient
and then you'll get the followers later
right what you need yeah he needs to
hire like a Tick-Tock camera person
right so like when they're doing the
surgery they have that song
he needs to surgically install a iPhone
in his own chest that's true he doesn't
have to do anything yeah talk that [ __ ]
you know man he doesn't watch like Dr
pimple popper though yeah and that's
your funnest that's that's great I'm a
fan really I'm a fan I don't want to be
he doesn't do anything to you when they
squeeze up the most gangster assists of
their life let's see that kind of stuff
it doesn't it's like a big thing to
watch even if you don't like satisfying
if you've never watch it right now the
chiropractor videos those are satisfying
also really but then but then where's
the line though you know what I mean
between pimple popping no before yeah
cosmetic surgery so to speak doing a
tick tock video versus like a
chiropractor you know well he's not
zooming it though because it's still
like on a tripod or someone's filming it
and he's that's the line he shouldn't be
filming himself yeah he's not being
interrupted but if he's if he's a
chiropractor and he's like breaking
people's arms because he was like trying
to film something in the middle of it
and that [ __ ] up yeah that's what
happened that's what's happening with
this [ __ ] surface or [ __ ] off yeah
you still [ __ ] up this is [ __ ]
malpractice you know what I mean
malpractice I just made that up right
now two pilots they like film all their
uh their flights
they're AirHeads
yeah that's that's the genre that's the
content I want to see see now that's
okay that's okay solid I think as long
as you're not filming it while you're
doing it yeah well if you're [ __ ]
flying a plane and then imagine you
crashed the plane because you were
filming a tick tock everyone's gonna be
like yo those Pilots are terrible that's
the same thing with this guy and I'll
come down to the contract if the
contract says I will film the surgery I
may [ __ ] up yeah sign here
you don't see sit like this what is that
it's not your pimple pops is it Santa
Claus
oh
okay that's not a cut okay oh my God he
said this was satisfying you didn't you
didn't feel satisfaction from them
oh God this person's disgusting dude oh
there's a lot in there that's what I'm
saying nah this is nasty it's gross but
I can't look away yeah that's all you
know what it looks like right here like
the neck and the cheekbone oh yeah no
this is nasty dude
it's not not nasty yeah
I'm sorry sorry
you know it's the holidays plus that's
what people got a lot of people why are
people so disgusting that's when you
[ __ ] go on that job or something go
on a job
without that [ __ ] out dude that helps
your skin care now she's getting the
scalpel now he's getting the cut
oh you're so [ __ ] [ __ ] is that he's
so [ __ ]
but why not because sometimes they gotta
get the sack in there because sometimes
like a sack will develop yeah
I like the big ones
how did they know there was more she's a
doctor uh it look you could see kind of
the mass in there
plus they come in there
there's clearly a second camera person
that's the real Point yeah she has two
hands on it yeah she got two hands on
that yeah and then she's not trying to
be the star her skills are the stars
right you know this ain't front facing
cam can we see one of these guys videos
one of these guys
stop real quick
Dr Daniel arenoff he's Russian
do you speak Russian but he is from
Australian what's that I can say
privilege
hi hello how are you do you know who
hospital is Hi how are you that's good
what's that I said do you know who has
Bula is no that's right really I like
him wait what's his homie's name the one
his rival Abdul Rose
I watch him more this is little guys
it's the little guys that were oh yeah
yeah I think I was talking about dude
you know is not even on Instagram as
much as Abdul dude yes he gotta catch up
to weird post though man he just be
confident [ __ ] find a video on this
guy without just seeing all the articles
about how he got banned me too I'm
fascinated with the Russian anything
Russian cosmetic surgeons it was it's
usually Russian girls for me
it's the opposite for me dude now the
closest was uh Romanian
sorry that's not even the same thing but
somehow similar the only it's like I
understand that it's that logic yeah
it's because they were a part of the
Soviet Union yeah I think I'm sure they
have similar texts they're part of the
Eastern black you know what I mean yeah
I can't find this full stuff it's like
all blocked and stuff oh that makes
sense yeah he got banned right isn't
that how the article this one maybe this
one's no no this is a uh oh this is a a
um oh this is my full my homie Zion this
is one of those like reaction ones where
they're like watching a video of a [ __ ]
put him in your homie he's a jab Walker
or what is it who's Zion dude just calm
down Zion
man you got to get rid of your dancer
names by the time you hit 30 though you
can't be like yo what's up my name is
airplane you know what I mean like
you're [ __ ] 30 years old shut the
[ __ ] up dude your name is [ __ ]
Daniels Richards do dancers have dancer
names to Richard is that pretty common
in the dance there's a lot of dancer
names yeah that's an example of a dancer
tell them you're a real dancer now I
don't have a dancer no come on you do
what's my dancer name isn't it like ant
some [ __ ] uh
the rest of this but here we go
can we hear this
she didn't even look like she had a lot
of Saturn necks
say that to her
[Laughter]
that's crazy when you know girls are
actually pretty and then they destroy it
because they have that body dysmorphia
stuff and they think they need to fix it
and I'm like damn you're going back
to fix it I know right
to me it's crazy when you know those
lips are just like those are not real
human lips and then it's like mixed with
the cheekbone that's like that's not
even real and I heard I heard the lip
stuff it doesn't last so you have to
keep going back yeah it's because it's
like filler right yeah
because everyone wanted to be Joker when
that movie came out because all the
girls started copying back
in the [ __ ] lips with the Kardashians
and the Joker seem so competitive
thank you
foreign